[Musique]
comme chaque lundi est les principaux
résultats sportifs du week end c'est
avec vous mais quel ennemi d' eurobonds
soir dans un grégory analystes sport de
la rédaction tv 78 du football pour
commencer avec une rencontre très locale
un derby heavy noir match en retard de
d2 de district guyancourt recevez
villepreux une rencontre qui commence
fort après seulement deux minutes de jeu
d'aiguillon courtois marque par l'intimé
l'intermédiaire de l'attaquant aurélien
lancé cueillis à froid les villes prose
y encaissent un deuxième but moins de
cinq minutes plus tard par l'inévitable
aurélien dans ces matches ne s'arrangent
pas pour les visiteurs troisième but sur
63 à 0 ce sera le score à la mi-temps en
deuxième période villes pro se ressaisit
poussent pour revenir dans le match mais
les joueurs de patrick et dominguez sont
maladroits dans le dernier geste ce sont
finalement les gluons courtois qui
inscriront le dernier but de la partie
en contre
score final 4 à 0 on a maîtrisé le match
du début à la fin on mène 3-0 quand même
au bout d'une demi heure de jeu donc
c'est quand même un signe d'une bonne
maîtrise pourquoi je suis satisfait du
match qu'on a fait surtout qu'on sortait
deux revers très dur on a pris deux fois
3-0
donc c'est important de se rassurer
défensivement et et faire du bien au
groupe dans les têtes surtout au
classement guyancourt remontée se
retrouve septième de son côté à
villepreux et désormais lanterne rouge
de ce championnat avec un seul nul
depuis le début de la saison ça commence
à être inquiétant prochain match le
dimanche 10 novembre du en cours recevra
l'équipe 2 de trappes et villepreux
accueillera houdan donc voilà pour le
clin d'oeil locale ce derby saint
quentinois y avait aussi de la coupe de
france ce week-end en football ont joué
ce week-end le 6e tour déjà vers cette
dernière représentant yvelinois dans la
compétition a eu très chaud face à viry
châtillon et versez y est classé une
division au dessus de leurs adversaires
en nationale 3 sont allés s'imposer
après une stressante séance de tirs au
but après avoir concédé le match nul et
vierge
il emporte 5 à 4 un résultat qui leur
suffit à se hisser au septième tour
comme la saison dernière au rendez-vous
sera programmée le 17 novembre prochain
avec l'entrée des clubs de ligue 2 et du
rugby aussi dans les yvelines en
fédérale 2 a plaisir à réaliser une
belle opération ce week-end lors de la
6e journée les hommes de sébastien
roncalli se sont imposés sur la pelouse
de l'amicale sarcelles ce dimanche le
score 22 à 14
une victoire qui permet aux plaisirs wa
de monter à la huitième place 5 et un
bilan de 2 victoires 1 nul et 3 défaites
en écoute l'entraîneur de l'équipe
ce résultat effectivement il
pour essayer de se projeter dans ce
milieu de tableau à voir la
qualification
maintenant le prochain blog est
déterminant l'armée d'europe ou dimanche
marche arrêt et après on a trois matches
dont deux à domicile sur des mêmes
niveaux clés au classement du rugby
encore avec le championnat de fédérale 3
lors de la 6e journée vers celle promue
cette année dans la division a réalisé
une très belle performance à domicile en
s'imposant sur son terrain contre eux ou
dans le derby yvelinois le score est
sans appel 46 à 17
un résultat qui fait leur bonheur les
verser entre dans le top 5 de leur poule
avec un bilan de 3 victoires 1 nul et 2
défaites depuis le début de la saison
merci michael ces résultats et bien
d'autres encore aussi des annonces de
rencontres des reportages dans votre
émission de 7,8 sport et c'est à
retrouver bien sûr après ce journal sur
tv 78